what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to create something
special that will change the planet so
to help you on your journey I started
the mentor me Series and the goal here
is to try to hang around people who have
done a lot more than us who achieved
massive success and hopefully by hanging
around them a little bit longer some of
their mindsets their attitudes their
beliefs the way they see the world will
seep in to us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we're
gonna learn from Malcolm Gladwell and
some of his best advice from
david-and-goliath mentor me Malcolm
[Music]
you
I arrived with the book idea for the
book because I had done this piece for
The New Yorker some years ago called how
David beats Goliath about a guy in
California who coached his his
daughter's twelve-year-old basketball
team all the way to the national
championships even though they were a
group entirely without talent or skill
and he did it by for those of you or
basketball fans by playing the
full-court press every minute of every
game a really really really radical form
of that full-court press the most
aggressive form you can and I was I just
thought that story was hilarious but
also really interesting because I loved
the way in which he would refused to
give up so he had here he was touched he
was going to nothing about basketball
coaching a team of girls without any
obvious skills in the area and the
normal response to people in those
situations is either to say it's
pointless and lose by 30 points a game
or to try desperately to play by the
rules of everyone else like to play the
way everyone else is playing and try and
catch up which would be impossible in
this season and he chose option C which
was to hell with it
let's play in this way that's so deeply
subversive that you know the other team
isn't gonna know what hit them
and that that just that story just
stayed with me and I thought it would be
really fun to write a book about those
kinds of strategies so there's this
really interesting fact that a very
large percentage a much larger
percentage of successful entrepreneurs
are dyslexic than in the general
population and many of the Richard
Branson Paul Orfila Charles Schwab John
Chambers at Cisco I could go on Craig
McCaw at a cell phone pioneer the lists
of these guys are all dyslexic right
David Neil minute JetBlue and if you
talk to them they will explain to you
that they don't think they succeeded in
spite of their disability they think
they do succeeded because of it
for them and if you want and I sat down
with a two dozen of these guys I've got
I get so obsessed the beginning of my
book in the middle of my book was
talking to dyslexic entrepreneurs and
their stories are all the same they all
look back and will tell you you know if
it hadn't have been for the fact that I
couldn't read or read well in second and
third in fourth grade I would never have
and they start listing all the things
they were forced to do that proved to be
ultimately advantageous I would never
have learned how to listen I would never
been forced in second weight I was I
made friends with the smartest kid in
the class and I basically convinced him
to do my homework for me I can't tell
you many times I heard that so what are
they learning at that age they're
learning delegation they're learning how
to communicate with other people
motivate other people form a team I mean
they and they do that in Brian Grazer
the Hollywood producer who's dyslexic
his whole thing was he would he figured
out how he would fail his test so they
would go in and he would talk is great
up from a de to a C so from the age of
this high he's learning negotiation
right by the end but timing hits college
he's brilliant at it
and then what did he do he becomes a
Hollywood producer what is that about
it's about negotiation among other
things and he's been practicing his
entire life so this a weird thing where
he would say as difficult as my dyslexia
was and for all of these people their
childhoods were not fun I mean I
interviewed Gary Cohn
I was the president of Goldman who's our
family dyslexic his childhood just
sounds
I mean dark and miserable no one thought
he was capable of doing schoolwork I
thought he was they were amazed with the
googling graduate from high school
despite that they all look back and say
you know what it was a desirable
difficulty it was I was taught I was
forced to learn stuff I would never even
have thought about in order to learn the
things that really need to be learned we
require a certain level of adversity the
trick is figuring out what that
adversity ought to look like
right and that's like I said something
that's that is a can only be decided on
a case-by-case basis it's gonna be
different for you than it is for me it's
not enough to have a great idea and the
focus and the conscientiousness to see
it to fruition you must have the
strength and the resolve and the courage
to pursue that idea even when the rest
of the world thinks you're insane time
and time again if you look at the
stories of extraordinarily important
entrepreneurs there is almost always a
moment when they are the only ones who
believe in the value of what they're
doing you know I tell in my book the
story of my book David and Goliath the
story of ink of our comrades IKEA and
the crucial moment in the in the story
of IKEA is when he faces a boycott from
the other furniture manufacturers in
Sweden and he's about to go out of
business and in desperation he moves his
operations across the Baltic Sea from
Sweden to Poland and sets up shop in
Poland and that's what IKEA is IKEA is
essentially furniture ship flat made in
Poland that's the original elevator
pitch for IKEA what's interesting about
that is he does it in 1961 at the height
of the Cold War at a time when East and
West Communist world and free world are
closer to outright war than at any other
time in history a guy living in the West
Sweden crosses the pond to Poland the
Iron Curtain and sets up shop you cannot
imagine what a controversial move that
was that's like that would be like
Walmart open operations in North Korea
literally it's on that level of kind of
eyebrow-raising you've got to be kidding
me
who is this guy kind of thing but he
does it and he persists and he turns his
back on all those critics why because he
is a deeply disagreeable person didn't
need people to agree with him right and
that's how he's able to build IKEA into
this extraordinary runaway success story
that's very hard to do as human beings
we are hard-wired to want the approval
of our peers i retell the story of david
and goliath to start the book because if
you look at the story closely every
you think was a disadvantage about David
actually isn't and Goliath is not what
he looks like he looks like this
indomitable giant
in fact he probably had a medical
condition called acromegaly which is
sort of a side thing you bring a
medicine in the Bible do it's because if
you the minute you started digging into
these things you discover these little
pockets have been arguing about these
things for years for 50 years
endocrinologists have been arguing about
whether Goliath had a tumor on his
pituitary gland and we should explain
his height because when you have a tumor
in your to eteri gland it over you won't
produce human growth hormone and you
can't really enjoy the giant red this
condition other than foot for a be seven
foot four yeah but one of the side
effects is that it can constrict your
optic nerves and leave you largely with
very very limited eyesight so one of the
explanations for why Goliath behaved so
strangely and why he doesn't perceive
that David is not intending to fight off
david comes down the mountain and he's
got no sword and no armor he clearly is
not intending to fight a sword fight and
Goliath just sits there like he's
oblivious well the answer is maybe he
could only see this far right so it
changes everything and you realize wait
a minute the Giant is weighed down by a
hundred pounds of armor and can't see
anything right he's like like this right
so anyway I do more with that story but
it's all about this trying to get people
to take a step back and understand that
we couldn't give up because we have
these look or feel powerless because we
have these empty definitions or flawed
definitions of advantage if you've read
you know innovators dilemma
that's what innovators dilemma is all
about right the disruptive outsider is
the one who is incapable of meeting the
marketplace needs as the market is
traditionally defined they can't do it
right so what do they do they they try a
completely new half assed approach which
in the beginning doesn't work right but
but that very nature of trying something
completely outside the mainstream they
end up appending the were they any good
they would never be forced to do that so
same kind of principle nobody who is
talking about your book in the
mainstream media is mentioning the
element you say that there are three
things it's faith courage and
determination yeah
nobody's talking about faith it's it's
not thing I mean this book began as I
just wanted in the manner of my previous
books to do this kind of use a lot of
social science work through theories
tell some stories about the fact that
disadvantages are often advantageous and
have advantages can be but by the end of
the book I realized that what I really
wanted to talk about was faith was about
the weapons of the Spirit I have a
chapter where I talk about this little
town in the mountains of France a
journalist it was a bunch of Hyuga knows
of a dissident Protestant sect in a very
Catholic country up in the mountains
during the Second World War they decided
they were gonna let they were going to
harbor any Jewish refugees that came to
their door and they Jewish refugees came
by the thousands they took them in and
they told the Nazis we're taking them in
if you want to come and get them we're
not going to give them to you we don't
care what you do to us it's this
extraordinary story and I and if you
read into it they had nothing they had
no resources no weapons they refused to
lie they so they weren't using deceit
all they had was their faith and that
was enough they felt that their faith
was every bit to match for whatever the
Nazis threw at them and I you cannot
read I don't care if you are the most
dyed-in-the-wool atheist you cannot read
that story and not come away with a
renewed appreciation for the power that
faith gives people thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd
love to know what did you learn from
this video that you're going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
for your business it was the single most
important lesson that you learned leave
it down in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Dave Gardner Dave
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and for doing
that YouTube review on it I really
really really appreciate the support and
I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book
I'm doing a little review of your one
word which is by Evan Carmichael so
thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon